foreign
[Music]
this is Far and Away the most dangerous
thing we've ever attempted
we've been working on this for years
we're going to shoot it in Norway and
it'll be a motorcycle jump off a cliff
into a base jump
I want to do it since I was a little kid
it all comes down to one thing
the audience
there's a lot going into this stunt so
Tom put together this master plan to
coordinate all of these experts in each
of the particular disciplines involved
to make this whole thing happen John and
I are jumping out of the helicopter he's
gonna chase me that's what we say to
each other don't be careful be confident
a year of Base training Advanced guide
up training a lot of canopy skills a lot
of tracking Tom Cruise these amazing
individuals you tell them something and
he just locks it in his sense of spatial
awareness he's the most aware person
I've ever met
lots of practice on stability and Free
Fall trekking with John and miles in the
air doing lots of different positioning
like there were two men team in the air
coming on top of each other below each
other backtracking front tracking you
know we've drilled and drilled and
drilled
when you do a lot of jumps back to back
the canopy control skills improve a lot
we have three open canopies which is a
good thing the training has gone really
well it's a progressive massive loops
make the cube how are you great day man
this is the next part of training right
here at the Motocross let's do it
so we built a motocross track
getting Compton the Motocross so he's
currently jumping 70 80 foot table tops
great time in the air great positioning
on the bike Landing world I have to get
so good at this that there's just no way
that I miss my marks that's good come a
little closer to me coming up with the
stunt is only one of the technical
challenges the other is putting a camera
in a place that you can see where Tom is
doing it finding the right lens the
right platform the right medium even two
years ago the cameras didn't exist that
would allow us to do what we're trying
to do today how do we involve the
audience I just want to give them that
thrill that means the camera has to be
in front of Tom and as close to him as
possible feels like you're going over
the camera yes very cool
[Music]
train and drill every little aspect over
and over and over and over again they
were doing 30 jumps a day getting to a
point where he was just a machine I mean
over 500 skydoms
that's what we do over 13
000 Motocross jumps
[Music]
all right it's gonna be fun oh it's
great
replica of this ramp in England and a
quarry we filled the Quarry with
cardboard boxes which were there to
catch the motorcycle the reason why we
did that is so that Tom could simulate
the jungle how fast should I go off what
distance do I travel we built models of
different ramps at different angles to
calculate what Tom's trajectory would be
we have to be able to consistently
predict where Tom is going to be in
three-dimensional space we're gonna have
a GPS chip on me and that recorded every
single one of Tom's jumps along with his
ground speed whether there was a
headwind whether there was a crosswind
and by doing this multiple times we were
able to get a consistent set of data so
that each take we can see what height I
am so this way we can set drones and
cameras into places where I can go right
into close-up rule one don't hit me with
it because if we do it all we don't
capture it right what's the point let's
do it guys ready yep always grab my
earplugs so I don't hear myself scream
we are already ready
he is me hitting certain speeds and
being consistent with that there's no
speedometer so I do it by sound and feel
of the bike
and then as I depart the bike I'm using
the wind that's hitting me here and I'm
cupping my chest that will give me lifts
[Music]
thank you all very much for your help
guys
foreign
[Applause]
[Applause]
we've been constructing this ramp over a
number of months everything here has to
be brought in by helicopter engineers
and technicians it's incredible what
they've done this is masterful today is
day one of principal photography and we
are starting in classic mission form
with the biggest stunt in the film what
we're doing here is I'm just doing jumps
just to warm up the body let's do it
just to get my tracking going and make
sure everything's working all right I'll
try not to smile
basically when he gets down and puts a
parachute around and goes and does the
bike job he'll actually know the weather
conditions in this area in the valley
and on the ground
and then he has to safely deploy a
parachute now he's in a rock ball with
walls all around him and he's got to fly
out of it
of course you know when something's been
done for the first time you can't help
but worry a little bit about how it's
really going to turn out for the jump
like this the challenge is finding the
cameras it's the amount of preparation
and then it's weather do you want the
light to be right you want the clouds to
be right Misty but not foggy this
weather right here is exactly what we're
looking for
about 10 minutes away from coming up
here landing and doing the actual class
sounds good we're in motion see you soon
now we're gonna set the frames with this
camera ship with the Drone just to
verify everything that we're gonna get
ready
you know the only things you really have
to avoid while doing a stunt like this
is a serious injury or death here we go
you're riding a motorcycle which is
pretty dangerous on top of a ramp that's
elevated off the ground so if you come
off the ramp that's gonna be very bad
you're falling if you don't get a clean
exit from the bike and you get tangled
up with it if you don't open your
parachute or you're not going to make it
three two one
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thanks mate I think I can hold to the
bike a little longer
thank you
pretty much the biggest stunt in cinema
history
Tom Cruise just rode a motorcycle off a
cliff six times today
[Music]
thank you
Far and Away the most dangerous thing
we've ever attempted the only thing that
scares me more is what we have planned
permissioning
[Music]